c'est quoi l'identité vous savez au
début quand je commence à réfléchir un
peu sur la notion d'identité
j'ai directement relié l'identité à la
nationalité en réfléchissant en creusant
un peu je me suis rendu compte que
l'identité c'est pas ça ou du moins ce
n'est pas que ça parce que l'identité
c'est beaucoup plus complexe c'est
défini par nos actions par nos qualités
par le défaut par nos interactions avec
les autres et c'est beaucoup plus
profond même il est faux de parler des
entités comme comme étant quelque chose
de simple l'identité et les pluriels une
personne par exemple elle peut
totalement se sentir femme fegan
bouddhiste française féministe
communiste et tout ça va à la fois parce
que l'identité ça se construit et ça se
construit notamment grâce aux autres et
je vous entends un exemple et un certain
temps je partis en voyage avec des amis
et on était 4 on a pris l'avion et puis
on dormait dans un hôtel c'est assez
drôle et fit la joie nous balader elle
soit on joue aux cartes c'est sympa mais
mais pendant tout le voyage un de mes
amis semblaient préoccupés et pas l'air
d'aller très bien il passe un peu ce
jour nos téléphones
il revenait triste soir et nous dans
tout ça va dans les deux posé la
question on lui demande et on me disait
ça va il n'a répondu que oui ça allait
il fallait pas s'en faire jusqu'au soir
où il est revenu dans la chambre on leur
a posé cette question
on l'a dit ça va et puis il a craqué
il a craqué et il nous a avoué que sa
mère avait un cancer alors à ce moment
là on a un peu fallait peut-être que
vous j'ai ouvert la bouche ouverte on
savait pas trop quoi dire quoi faire mes
premiers réflexes
allez le voir lui dire qu'il n'était pas
seul
quand il était là pour lui qu'on voulait
l'aider on l'apporté des conseils de
l'aide et surtout surtout le dire qu'il
n'était pas seul ce moment là cet
instant là que j'ai passé que nos amis
ces instants dont je me rappellerai
toute ma vie ça l'instant qui marquons
l'adolescence et j'en suis sûr parce
qu'après ce moment là je me sentais plus
même s'ils ont l'impression d'avoir
changé d'avoir grandi de porter un
regard différent sur les personnes
j'étais parvenu le même elle avait
surtout surtout l'impression d'avoir
réussi à aider quelqu'un et à aider
quelqu'un
seulement lui parlant et tout ça tout ça
grâce à l'empathie mais c'est quoi
l'empathie l'empathie vient directement
du grec en pâte s et empâté ça veut dire
qu'ils se passionnent
parce que l'empathie celle envie de
comprendre celle envie de comprendre les
autres son envie d'aller plus loin de
comprendre le ressentiment dans une
relation en pâtit on se met à la place
des autres tout en gardant ses propres
valeurs et l'empathie c'est quelque
chose qui est directement relié à
l'ecoute d'altruisme où l'amour et les
personnes en pratique c'est souvent les
personnes un peu sensibles par exemple
la personne en pratique par excellence
c'est celle qui va pleurer devant la fin
de titanic par exemple mais l'empathie
l'empathie sa partagent une ligne fine
extrêmement fine avec la compassion la
compassion ce mois qui vient du latin
formé du préfixe coumes qui veut dire
avec et du suffixe pâte your qui veut
dire souffrance dans la compassion
on a une idée d'être avec la souffrance
on unités de souffrance d'une douleur
qui doit de réparer et donc on a
toujours une personne qui
émotionnellement beaucoup plus forte que
l'autre
une relation de compassion par exemple
ça secret va vous êtes chez vous vous
êtes chez vous vous allumez votre télé
et vous voyez à l'autre bout du monde il
ya une catastrophe naturelle des
personnes sont mortes nous ont été
ravagés et vous voyez bien un numéro un
numéro lequel vous pouvez appeler pour
donner de l'argent et pour aider ces
personnes et bonnes relations compassion
ça va se passer comme ça vous allumez
votre télé voyez ça vous sentez triste
vous donner de l'argent vous sentez
mieux parce que dans une relation de
compassion on a toujours l'impression
que la souffrance de l'autre ne peut que
disparaître si on n'en absorbe une
petite partie est donc la différence de
l'empathie on se met à la place de
l'autre tout en oubliant totalement qui
on est c'est ça qui m'intéresse dans
l'empathie on se met à la place de
l'autre tout en gardant ses propres
valeurs et du coup on absorbe de l'autre
non une partie de sa douleur nous une
partie de la souffrance une partie de sa
vision sur le monde une partie de sa
compréhension et on apprend de lui et
l'empathie s'appelle quelque chose de
simple par exemple aider quelqu'un qui
arrive pas à réaliser une tâche basique
l'empathie ça peut être plus profonds
comme proposé une personne âgée de lui
et a traversé la rue et je sais je sais
que tout ce que je dis là aujourd'hui
devant vous c'est bien beau c'est beau
vous me direz que c'est beau tout ça
mais je sais aussi que certains adultes
me diront que malheureusement c'est pas
vrai et malheureusement dans la vie ce
n'est pas l'empathie qui règne mais bien
trop souvent l'hypocrisie qui vient très
souvent l'empathie et mastien hypocrisie
par des personnes qui recherchent un
bénéfice personnel aux relations
humaines
et c'est vrai je pas vous mentir c'est
vrai l'hypocrisie
elle présente
très présente prenez un politicien par
exemple c'est un peu son rôle
un politicien il peut dire qu'il n'en
pâtisse totalement avec la pauvreté
extrême
alors que c'est un rêve dans une société
l'empathie nous aide à vivre ensemble et
dans ce vivre ensemble
j'entends aussi apprendre des autres et
apprendre des autres
c'est notamment à prendre des aînés
ration plus âgés vous savez mon père me
dit souvent max je ne suis pas plus
intelligent que toi
j'ai seulement plus d'expérience parce
que dans la vie on se forge grâce à
l'expérience et notamment grâce à
l'expérience émotionnelle être engagée
dans une relation empathique
ça vous fait grandir sauf à apprendre de
l'autre m'étrangler dans une relation
hypocrite ça peut vous vacciner contre
ce type de comportement mais l'empathie
intelligence émotionnelle
le fait de chercher à comprendre c'est
un choix et c'est un choix que vous que
nous nous seuls sont libres de prendre
y'a pas longtemps j'ai bien un article
c'est donc sur un sur la zdf une
personne à madrid qui donc passer ses
journées dans le métro à madrid parce
que l'hiver il fait froid à madrid et
puis un jour en pleine journée et il est
mort est décédée
et puis là rester là une journée entière
les gens passaient devant lui les
écouteurs dans les oreilles les jeux sur
leur téléphone sans même le regarder et
vous savez qui est la première personne
qui est venu le voir c'est l égard du
métro pour le virer parce que le métro à
les fermer
et c'est là c'est à ce moment là j'ai
envie de vous dire que c'est votre choix
c'est à vous de choisir est-ce que
voulez vous mettre à la place des autres
est ce que vous voulez vous investir
pour les autres vous voulez faire comme
si de rien n'était vous savez comme le
dit yuval nos harari c'est la première
fois la première fois dans l'histoire
récente de l'humanité qu'on a absolument
aucune idée à quoi notre monde va
ressembler en 50 ans n'a aucune idée et
pourtant une chose dont on est sûr c'est
que demain ils changent constamment et
dans un monde qui change constamment la
nouvelle génération
nous on aura besoin de se réinventer
constamment et ce changement constant
d'identité salué ces deux choses une
stabilité mentale une stabilité
émotionnelle et l'intelligence
émotionnelle
c'est la première chose que l'on devrait
apprendre à nos enfants
j'aimerais bien revenir un peu sauf que
je vous avais dit avant
après ce moment partage avec mes amis je
me sentais plus le même
j'ai l'impression d'avoir changé d'avoir
grandi je porte un regard différent sur
les personnes tout ça grâce à l'empathie
parce que l'empathie c'est se mettre à
la place des autres
c'est apprendre des autres et c'est
grandir comme personne parce que le vrai
changement d'identité passe par
l'empathie
merci
[Applaudissements]